reason not to see number one the pacing
I personally felt that um the pacing was
off the tone shifting was happening an
awful lot and there was a lot of it
seemed very drag out and then a little
choppy at times to the editing of it was
kind of a turn off to me on a technical
level i agree with you with it's like
certain certain scenes go on for a while
and then they'll cut to this really
short scene and then they'll go to an
long action scene and they'll cut up to
this really long talk scene and it's
like there's a lot of tonal shifts then
since they're trying to bring it into
Lord of the Rings universe you have like
humorous stuff and light stuff and then
you mix with this really heavy mark
stuff yeah it didn't really bug me that
much but I do agree the pacing is kind
of weird the facing to involving me a
lot yeah Jerry Jerry you're not getting
it you're wrong about the pacing oh I'm
sorry yeah let me let me admit that
you're not you're not getting i missed
the pacing was off this was decision
number one writing and directing issues
here's where I felt I was most
disappointed with the film was you know
honestly I thought one of the mistakes
that they made was actually bringing
Peter Jackson back to direct was because
it felt like Lord of the Rings but
exceptionally smaller and I would have
preferred a different take on the film I
get what you're saying there I mean this
was one of those things where when I
heard Galen de Toro was attached to it I
was like oh that's really cool yeah I'm
like he's the guy if it's not Peter
Jackson he's the guy who I would want to
do it and then he backed off it was the
sort of thing work Peter Jackson came
back and I was like well I know he's
gonna do a good job on a lot of stuff
but it's not as exciting it you can tell
he loves the world but it might be to a
point where there aren't a lot of people
to challenge the vision around yeah
I think the film lacked a lot of heart I
can never get it fully emotionally
pulled into the movie it seemed like an
observation of this world rather than
being into the world again it looks
great but it seemed more about the
technical special effects and all that
more than it did about the actual
storytelling so yeah I don't necessarily
think that it's not about the
storytelling it's only about the
technical stuff I just think that it's
kind of like it couldn't decide what to
focus on we've got this guy's story he
dealing with that conflict then we're
going to jump over to this guy store and
he's dealing with this and then we're
gonna bring in another character from
the other side of you know yeah middle
order that he's having a problem here
and it's all sort of to set up that
there is trouble afoot in middle earth
but it does kind of block you from fully
connecting to stuff and I'm not one of
those people who's like it's gotta be
like the book but the book is Bilbo's
story and a lot of his like his he's
definitely a prominent character like it
is his story in some ways but they do
shift the focus to other things a lot to
that DC you're talking about Bilbo and
that was my problem with the film was
despite the fact that there were solid
performances in the film I still did not
really give a [ __ ] about anyone in this
movie oh I didn't I wasn't rooting for
Bilbo I wasn't really rooting for the
doors and the combination of trying to
include the Lord of the Rings tonality
into it I found the humor to be kind of
eternal at times it seemed to be rather
than an annoyance than an actual
pleasure and fun joy to experience I
didn't mind the humor cuz like I know
like the movie begins the width book
does like it's and again it's not all
about being like the book but I was at
least prepped for that mm-hmm and I know
that you know it's like I respect they
want to bring it in to lower the Rings
universe because even Tolkien was trying
to do that I don't know if they balanced
it all particularly well the way it
comes together in you know the editing
and the writing and stuff like that is a
little problematic i will give you I
just felt that the story itself could be
told in two movies I don't think it
needs to be told in three films it's
seen Peter Jackson seems to really be
stretching this thing
and I think he's going way beyond its
limits you know I've heard it said a few
times that a lot of this movie feels
like setup and yeah I kind of agree
there is a lot of setup and I'm some I
don't know how the next two movies are
going to go because it's like on the one
hand they get pretty far in The Hobbit
as I recall in the course of this movie
so I don't know what else they're adding
you know I don't know if some of the
setup will pay off more in the movies to
come but as of now I'm almost a little
worried about the next to it is because
I'm like how much more can you put in
and and is it so gonna be kind of off
balance or not yeah anchor some ppl are
defending the film compa saying like
well the first ones like a build-up well
I want more of a interesting build up a
night it's weird to me because I'm
looking at the film and I'm going it
looks great and the acting is good
everything seems kind of solid actually
yet it's still one of the movie was over
it still felt kind of block the doors
are our main character because it is you
know it is about the 14 of 10 see you do
kind of have this problematic ensemble
because it's a [ __ ] ton of people of him
but at least it's like you know gand out
at least getting out Thorin and Bilbo
should be sort of at the top of that of
you know the characters that we're
focusing on and they do sort of go more
into focusing on the dwarves and it does
sort of drop off Bilbo a little bit the
only thing I'm really comparing this
film on with Lord of the Rings is
execution because Lord of the Rings has
so many characters and each film felt
like a complete film and yeah the thing
is this has an ensemble too but as far
as the dwarfs go I didn't find them that
interesting I just did not and it they
all kind of bathe the same except for
its leader yeah I just felt that they
were the first hour to was just so much
talking does not stop talking and it was
just so blah blah blah blah blah
and he just kept taking forever get
going every every scene I felt could
have been trimmed down except for the
Golem see that's the one seemed rather
like it longer yeah maybe that seemed
longer just like it watch it a plate of
that one yeah and this film every scene
was just so dragged out to me is like
come on man trim it down at least it
wasn't like watchman we realize it Mon
man speed up the frame yeah we don't
need to see him pick up a pen and a
slow-motion hood some of those scenes go
on a while I never found myself bugged
by I still liked watching it I was get
Jerry Jerry it was boring devised wrong
I'm sorry in his wrong I'm just off my
game today was boring it was born okay
all right I accepted this film on its
own merits so I wasn't watching it
compared into the lord of the rings
trilogy the whole time because all I
mean I i love that trilogy but i've only
seen them once or twice so i don't
really remember it to a full extent to
get parrot detail by detail same here
but all I know that this is those films
were pulled off magically and this film
that not feel majestic to me see how I
thought it got the majesty again I'd the
word I keep going back to his kind of it
is just kind of WAP sided like it's like
the Lord of the Rings movies you never
question the flow really or at least I
didn't it was like everything seems to
lead logically to the next yeah and even
when they're jumping back and forth it
all makes sense and in this movie it
just sort of felt a little obsolete
technically it's all there y mo sionally
I didn't feel like yeah it's not
balanced out yay and this for me this
should be a good emotional experience
you know not not a lot of not a letdown
Gary live now I'm sorry yeah it's okay I
could use a blow job right now
what decision number two I saw the the
white orchid I thought the effects of
him were awesome they were I thought it
was no no well I know on headache he was
only was one of the characters were I
didn't think the effects were bad by any
stretch of the imagination but he was
the one character where I've kept going
back and forth as to whether I felt he
looked good oh really i thought you up
and that first the first time you see
him in that big battle when they're
showing the flashback between the
dwarves and them that was that was a
crazy cool fight scene i thought i got a
cool fights you get was scary well I'd
see that was dude that was there like I
liked the intro there was times when I
kind of found myself trying to figure
out if he was real or CG and not in the
good way oh I kind of get what you mean
actually cuz I was doing that too I
thought he was cg at first but then when
he started talking later on I was like
oh is this a real guy that's actually
playing him I just kind of felt like
that subplot was kind of crow boarded
what I will say about that subplot is
that it felt like it could have been
wrapped up in this movie like I was
watching it thinking yeah I could see
how it's personal but why is this the
main focus I like the character but as
far as this beam thorens main villain I
think they could have put that attention
elsewhere yeah it's just it almost
diluted the the point for me as I yeah
it's like we're going back to the Lonely
Mountain to reclaim you know our kingdom
from small but there's also this guy
who's coming after us but there's
trouble over here yeah and then there's
this stuff